thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
the first thousand people to click on
the link in the description can get a
one month free trial of skillshare's
premium membership so you can start
exploring your creativity today
[Music]
if you've taken a biology class at some
point you likely had to sit down to a
picture of a cell
it was vaguely oval shaped and filled
with circles and squiggly lines and your
task was to look at those circles and
lines and assign them labels like
vesicle or nucleus and this exercise has
its benefits but at the same time the
picture it paints of a cell is by
necessity static and uniform the reality
is that cells may be full of analogous
parts but their lives and physical
appearance can appear vastly different
when compared to each other the bodies
of multicellular organisms like us are
built on that principle with a diversity
of cells dedicated to different tasks
but we can see it even more starkly in
the lives of single-celled eukaryotes
these are organisms who have managed to
make an entire way of life out of a
single cell taking on many different
forms to do so even as the inner parts
remain approximately the same the final
results can be wildly different whether
you're looking at the flexible form of
an amoeba or the determined shape of a
diatom
here on journey to the microcosmos we
often focus on the organisms on their
fascinating physiology and lives as they
navigate the world around them
but what about the even smaller world
inside of them
if you think of a cell as its own little
world a little society built on
chemistry and biology one of its most
important tasks is establishing its
boundaries separating and protecting the
inside of the cell while still leaving
it just open enough to bring in
essential nutrients from the outside the
essential component here is the plasma
membrane a double layer of fatty acids
that surrounds the cell and allows some
things to pass while keeping the cell
protected
but for different protists the cell
membrane may not be quite enough to
establish the kind of boundaries it
needs
ciliates like these palagatrix encase
their plasma membrane within a larger
structure called the pellicle which has
structures to define the organism's
shape and anchor their many hairy cilia
other organisms supplement their plasma
membrane with another exterior wall like
this colony of green algae called
pediastrum
each of these cells is encased in a
protective cell wall
what comes next after the boundaries
have been set is well
everything it is one big soup of life
organelles and nutrients swimming in the
watery broth of the cytoplasm
and just like a good soup there is a
delicate balance to the cytoplasm when
you're living in a watery environment
with a thin membrane separating you from
the outside world water can seep through
a little bit of that water might be fine
but too much can be dangerous we've even
seen microbes burst open and die when
they've been pushed past their watery
limits
but microbes are not passive in the face
of this danger if you look at the edge
of this frontonia vernalis you can see
its solution at work
there are canals all pointed toward the
same clear circular region that area is
not just some blank space it is a
contractile vacuole swelling up with
water until it is full and when it is
full you can see it contract and push
the water out of the cell through tiny
pores leaving the world within
balanced
and as we travel further inside this
world there is a flurry of activity not
all of which is visible to us much of
that activity is powered by the
mitochondria though unfortunately they
are a bit too small for us to easily see
but we think that the thin rods inside
this diatom might be the famous
powerhouses of the cell
the chemicals that mitochondria use to
generate power come from food and of
course microbes have found many creative
ways to obtain food some organisms make
their own turning light into sugar
through clever chemistry and
chloroblasts and even though
chloroplasts can come in different
shapes and sizes they're usually easy
enough to identify through their most
obvious trait their vibrant green color
derived from the light absorbing
chlorophyll that powers the chloroplast
except of course biology loves an
exception there are examples of other
colors in the chloroplast realm like in
red algae that have other pigments that
stain their chloroplasts red
whatever the color these are organisms
whose inner worlds can sustain
themselves as long as they get enough
light but other organisms have to go out
and seek their sustenance by finding
other organisms to eat and if that
sounds like a bit much to you i will
remind you
you are one of them so humans and other
organisms like us have to find a way to
introduce that food into their bodies
in some organisms that gate is called
the system and in this glaucoma the
system takes the form of an oval
flapping as the organism turns around
and assesses a possible meal but
swallowing food is only one step in the
process after it enters the organism's
body the food gets wrapped up in its own
little membrane like a present a present
stuffed with digestive enzymes that will
tear its contents apart
and just as with water the cell doesn't
necessarily want to keep all of this
digested food around for the rest of its
life so what doesn't get used gets
pooped out through the cytoproct and if
the mitochondria is the powerhouse of
the cell the cytoproct is the butthole
of the cell
and then of course there are other
specialized parts that help different
organisms manage the specific challenges
of their lifestyle like take this
luxodies which prefers to live in areas
of water that are lower in oxygen areas
that are to put it simply down down the
water column into the depths
but to get there the loxodies needs to
figure out just where down is so the
organism relies on its muller vesicles a
simple structure it's an organelle that
allows it to detect gravity the vesicle
holds a single mineral granule attached
to a psyllium and as gravity pulls on
the mineral the mineral pulls on the
cilium pointing the loxodies downward
like an inner compass
now if we take a step back and survey
these little worlds inside of organisms
it is remarkable to realize that these
organisms have built themselves
assembled and sustained by their own
reactions they have gathered and made
their resources and from it comes all of
these different parts that just seem to
work
there's so many bits of chemistry and
probability that have to come together
to make each of these tiny remarkable
lives happen
and at the center of so much of that
assembly is the nucleus those round
organelles that hold the dna that
describes the organism's existence
nuclei are universal among eukaryotes
though of course ciliates in all of
their contrarian glory have also managed
to make their own habits out of familiar
entities ciliates are not content to
just have one type of nucleus no they
have to the larger nucleus is called the
macronucleus and it is responsible for
the day-to-day genetic needs of the
organism whereas the smaller nuclei are
the micronuclei and their primary role
is to pass on genetic information during
sexual reproduction
it feels right to end with the nucleus
the part of the cell that ensures not
just the life of the organism itself but
also
of its progeny it is a map that is
passed on and shared promising the
creation
of new worlds to come
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and we would also like
to say thank you again to skillshare for
supporting this video we've discussed
skillshare many times and we've shared
courses that can help you with
everything from learning to paint with
watercolors to understanding how to
properly cook and prepare fish but what
if you are not feeling super confident
about starting down a new creative path
well skillshare is here to help you with
that as well
in the course confidence for creatives
host eugena washington will help you
develop some tools to help you reconnect
with your self-worth and continue to
grow your confidence to do the creative
work that you love
do you battle with imposter syndrome or
are you looking for a burst of
inspiration well if you answered yes to
either of those questions this class is
for you
skillshare is an online learning
community that can help you make 2022 a
year of new learning growth and
connection through creativity with so
much to explore and real world projects
to create skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth it's curated
specifically for learning meaning there
are no ads to distract you and they're
always launching new premium classes so
that you can stay focused on leveling up
your skills and also if you're one of
the first thousand people to click the
link in the description you can get a
one month free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
just like a cell is made up of many
organelles this channel is made up of
many people who want it to exist and
these people on the screen right now are
some of those people they're our patreon
patrons and if you would like this show
to continue existing and also to get
some cool perks one of them being
knowing you are instrumental to the
existence of this channel but others
being quite cool as well you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us i bet you can find a subscribe
button somewhere nearby